alors aujourd'hui je suis là pour faire
rêver
bien sûr vous aimeriez sûrement que je
vous parle de faire le la téléportation
d'une personne par exemple qui sort
terre que cette personne là pourrait
utiliser un appareil et c'est déplacer
instantanément ou presque jusqu'à la
planète mars dans un appareil similaire
bien sûr il faudrait qu'il ya un certain
temps pour transmettre l'information à
ce point de départ plus point d'arrivée
mais ce qu'on voudrait c'est d'être
capable de prendre un être humain par
exemple de le décomposer en petits
morceaux
en tout petits morceaux et de
reconstituer la même chose rendre jaloux
debout dans un sens c'est pas vraiment
ce dont je parle aujourd'hui mais je
vais faire un lien avec sa vers la fin
ça alors je vais vous parler au jeu
cette saison
je voudrais pas que le phénomène que je
vais vous est ce que je vais vous
expliquer nous permettent de faire des
télécopies c'est à dire que je voudrais
pas que ce phénomène la main permettent
de prendre une personne sur terre dans
la voyez une copie sur la planète 9 me
retrouvais avec 2 puis vous allez voir
que quand je vous explique que je vous
explique ce que c'est que la
téléportation quantique
on va obtenir comme propriété
effectivement on peut pas faire ça donc
ce serait une façon très naturelle de
faire de téléportation que je vous
montrais tout à l'heure
je n'aborde par les informations les
formations classiques
si ce qu'on a en général quand on
regarde les objets au niveau
macroscopique
par exemple si on regarde la tour eiffel
mais la tour eiffel était construite à
partir d'un clan c'est ce que quelqu'un
dise design cet objet là et ensuite le
cri des morceaux on les assemble y qu'on
ne construit un objet hyper complexe qui
la tour eiffel et si je voulais en faire
une copie
mais je pouvais repartir du même plan
vigie nage et reconstruire exactement
une copie conforme des tours eiffel au
niveau microscopique on est habitué que
les choses fonctionnent comme ça on est
ambitieux qu'on peut faire des copies
qu'on peut les faires conformes les uns
aux autres puis donc on serait par
exemple une copie des tours eiffel
mais au niveau relativement
microscopique même au niveau génétique
par exemple les chromosomes
c'est un système qui fonctionne aussi
par copie on part de certaines
informations qu'on trouve dans les
chromosomes et on peut la nature c'est
ce pour nous fait des copies de la lhjmq
souvent les chromosomes et on obtient
des copies conformes de l'information
qu'on avait précédemment
et c'est ce que nous permet de
construire des cellules quand sont des
êtres vivants alors la première surprise
dont je vous parlais secteur au niveau
des particules atomiques ou ce même
souhait tomic l'information cette règle
de façon différente
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas exactement
les mêmes propriétés que ce qu'on est
habitué au niveau conventionnel au
niveau macroscopique
alors vous posez peut-être la question
pourquoi est ce que ces différences
parce que les naturalistes et ici
les propriétés différentes de
l'information au niveau quantique au
team en lumière en trente ans d
expérience de stern égard lac 3922 qu'il
aurait du prix nobel en 1943 ça nous a
démontré que l'information coin sic
kiki relative à la physique quantique
est très différente de l'information à
laquelle on est habitué alors je prends
un exemple je prends mon anatomie si je
vous montre une particule un électron
grève est autour de la tombe
puis je vais vous faire un zoom sur
l'électron puis vous allez constater que
mon électrons une tête de biscuits
chinois
alors pourquoi j'ai choisi de vous
montrer les biscuits chinois c'est parce
que sinon faudrait que je donne un cours
de physique
ce que je veux pas faire ce que je vais
faire si vous utilisez l'énergie des
biscuits chinois
pour vous donner une idée de ce qui se
passe au niveau microscopique alors le
biscuit chinois il ya la propriété
suivante est la propriété que si je la
caf en deux j'attends de voir un début
de messages sur un des deux parties où
j'essaie de voir une fin de message sur
notre parti
mais au niveau microscopique j'ai pas la
possibilité d'obtenir le message au
complet je suis limité à faire des
observations comme donner de
l'information partielle
c'est ça que j'ai pas la capacité de
tout voir en même temps puis ça c'est
une chose qui est complètement contraire
celui-ci sert qu'au niveau macroscopique
on n'est pas du tout habitués avec ses
propriétés là au niveau macroscopique
on a l'impression de pouvoir prendre
l'information puis en faire une copie au
niveau microscopique au niveau
subatomiques on n'a pas la capacité
d'obtenir toute l'information
alors c'est pas par hasard si je me sers
et ces sujets là parce que mon mon sujet
de demain en général c'est l'information
secrète et l'expo graphie ce n'est pas
par hasard que je me suis retrouvé à
chercher et à tomber sur des
informations veuillez la téléportation
compter que vous allez voir une chose
aussi qui pas possible de faire au
niveau microscopique c'est prendre un
objet par exemple aux biscuits chinois
et d'en faire une copie conforme saison
de partir d'un biscuit chinois avec un
message de d'un qu'une boule de pâte
puis transformer ça en deux biscuits
chinois comptines le même message
c'est à dire qu'on a un phénomène d'un
oncle ou nage il était possible de
reproduire une information parce que si
je pouvais faire ça
si j'avais la capacité de
de partir de un biscuit chinois puis
d'en faire deux jeux pour en prendre
deux puis en faire quatre à prendre qu'a
pu en faire huit ans après tout les
ouvrir puis je verrai les deux morceaux
du message mais comme je l'aï dit
précédemment c'est impossible si je
biscuits chinois de voir les deux
morceaux du message en même temps j'en
vois seulement la moitié alors à cause
de ses propriétés là jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à l'invention de téléportation
quantique
on était limité que si je veux par
exemple prendre le contenu d'un biscuit
chinois
si je veux le prendre au point au filet
mené au point b mais la seule façon que
je connaissais c'est le même dans un
moyen de transport quelconque un camion
puis le télé place jusqu'au point b j'ai
une fois la capacité de l'ouvrir de les
lire
puis d'appeler au téléphone qui dira
l'autre le contenu c'était telle chose
parce que si je loue genre voire jusqu'à
moitié alors c'est la même chose je veux
tu es les parties je me transporter un
attente d'un endroit à un autre et que
je veux pas perdre l'information qui
caché dans ces particules la même façon
je devais transporté l'objet du point a
au point b et pas seulement transmettre
l'information qui caché dedans puis
éventuellement si on voulait transporter
une personne avec ses milliards de
molécules de particules d'atomes et
toute l'information qui cache à
l'intérieur
ben on est aussi là mêmes restrictions
que on peut prendre la personne au point
il aime non pour un bébé mais la seule
façon qu'on connaissait c'est de le
faire physiquement de prendre la
personne que de les déplacer
alors ce que je vais vous expliquer
maintenant c'est un phénomène qu'on
appelle la téléportation quantique qui
nous permet de faire la même chose de
prendre l'information caché dans un
système en points au filet mené au point
b mais d'une façon qui ne demande pas de
le déplacer physiquement
ce phénomène ne s'est basé sur
l'intrication quantique l'intrication
quantique ce phénomène qui était mis en
évidence en 1935
par einstein podolsky rosen ils ont
écrit un article où ils ont dit aux
fondateurs de la mécanique quantique les
boys si votre théorie est juste ça va
être bizarre parce que si votre théorie
est juste il va se passer des phénomènes
où l'information qui va se cacher dans
les systèmes quantiques votre partagé en
différents endroits
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intrication
c'est un gros mot ce intrication fâcher
les chercher une définition un tricks
intrication ce mot français qui veut
dire en mêlée ou qui veut dire
enchevêtrent ici des choses qui sont
attachées les unes aux autres qui sont
entremêlées les unes aux autres avec
l'intrication quantique ce phénomène où
on est différents systèmes qui concerne
l'information
mais ces informations là sont attachées
les unes aux autres bon un exemple s'il
vous plaît un exemple parce que la chose
suivante alors imaginé une paire de
biscuits chinois coantic qui sont
attachées par le phénomène qu'on appelle
l'intrication du biscuit show aquatique
sont attachés par des bouts de papier
comme ça comme les bouts de papiers que
contiennent à l'intérieur mais ayant la
propriété que si je les ouvre tous les
deux ils vont toujours s'ouvrir de façon
complémentaire c'est à dire que il y en
a un des deux qui va s'ouvrir sur la
première partie mais le deuxième à
s'ouvrir sur la deuxième partie
bon si je recommence
ça se pourrait que le premier sur la
deuxième partie deuxième sous la
première partie mais d'avoir les deux
qui sauve la même façon je devrais
jamais avoir ça alors le phénomène des
tri-nations sais que si je fais une
expérience d'ouvrir un biscuit que je
vois une moitié l'autre - claude
biscuits quelqu'un au bout si il veut
voir l'autre moitié ce qui est
surprenant là dedans c'est que si moi je
me trouve ici puisque l'autre personne
se trouve sur mars
il faut quand même avoir la relation que
six mois jean nouveau puis je veux de
moitié lui vaut ouvrir l'autre pivot
rond l'autre moitié nécessairement il ya
une espèce de communication entre les
deux qui dit
ben vu que les premiers ouverts d'un bar
le deuxième but ouvrir de l'autre alors
2935 pour nous années soixante dix les
tricks à sion quanti qui était purement
théorique puis dans les années 70 j'ai
eu des expériences en france qu'ils
aiment en évidence que l'intrication
courtier qui est un phénomène réel qui
est mis en évidence l'existence du
phénomène de façon expérimentale
puis en 1993 avec mes amis j'ai le
brassard
russell johnson williams utah jazz
bennett et hr perez
on a montré que l'intrication quantique
peut servir à faire de la téléportation
quantique que je vais maintenant vous
expliquer alors la téléportation
quantique
si on fait l'analogie avec les biscuits
chinois ça va me permettre de prendre
l'information qui caché dans le biscuit
y en a
puis de l'envoyer dans le biscuit et en
b en utilisant le fait que les lubies
scud droite sont dans l'état d'être
ication quantique
alors évidemment je peux vous donner
tous les détails mais ce que je vais
vous dire ce essentiellement comment ça
fonctionne
grosso modo il s'agit d'observer les
deux premiers biscuits chinois et de
leur demander êtes vous par hasard
intrigués les découvertes de la
téléportation pour sécuriser des
facialement sur cette opération là si on
peut poser cette question là puis
obtenir une réponse
ça veut effectivement produire l'effet
qu'on cherche évidemment si on regarde
les images sans pas étriqué parce que
c'est celui les deux droites sont
intriqués c'est pas celui gauche puis
celui du milieu sauf que si on pose la
question ça impose une réponse
puis le système va nous répondre à deux
ans oui je souhaite qu'à l'endroit donc
les deux se retrouvent étriqué par le
fait que j'ai posé la question
du coup même je détruis l'information
qui était présente
alors la chose que j'avais en eau que je
vous l'envoyez je viens de m'en
débarrasser je viens de le détruire
parce que j'ai un système
se trouvait dans un étau étriqué sauf
que la magie de la chose c'est que la
téléportation quantique fait que
l'information qui était cachée en a se
retrouve maintenant qu'elle cherbi alors
vous me direz est ce qu'on peut vraiment
faire ça
oui sauf que c'est un petit peu plus
seul
des fois ça répond oui on est étriqué
mon est étriqué à l'envers puis si ça
répond que c'est un trick à l'envers le
jeu représente sa part les lignes se
croisent à ce moment là le biscuit
chinois en b il peut tout à fait dans
les temps qui qu'on avait en eau qu il
faut faire une certaine correction il
faut le le flipper verticalement pour
obtenir la même chose que ce qu'on à vos
débuts alors imaginez maintenant comme
application de ça imaginez qu'on est sur
la terre aux biscuits chinois a avec la
moitié d'une part étriqué et que cette
part étriqué est en connexion avec un
autre biscuits chinois baic sur la
planète mars
parce que je prétends c'est que en
faisant une observation seulement sur la
terre sur la partie à et la partie
la moitié de la part intriqués si on lui
demande
etes-vous étriqué par hasard et bien si
ça nous répond à l'endroit
on veut transmettre un message radio
standard tu veux dire à la partie b que
on a observé que c'était l'endroit à la
partie b on va maintenant avoir une
copie exacte de ce qu'il y avait la
partie en eau début mais ce qu'ils
avaient en hausse était détruit
complètement pilot possibilité c'est que
ça nous répondent que c'est à l'envers
dans quel camp va transmettre un message
que veut dire à l'envers jusqu'à la
partie b puis elle a participé
on va faire une opération qui va
corriger le fait que c'est à l'envers
pour quand même se retrouver avec
l'information qu'on avait encore
alors dès le début en 1993 on a vu des
gens un certain nombre d'expériences qui
ont été faites mais la plus concluante
c'est ça qui était faite en 2012 aux
îles canaries alors osez canaris il ya
des fils y expérimentateurs qui ont
montré que on peut prendre une paire de
particules intriquées dans ce que c'est
c'est des particules de lumière des
photons et on a montré que le phénomène
de téléportation quantique est bel et
bien vrai sur une distance de 143 km
alors vous me direz pourquoi
spécifiquement ce qu'on a fait ça aux
îles canaries
c'est pas parce que parce qu'il ya mambo
mais c'est pas complètement indépendant
non plus c'est que sur une des deux il y
au télescope astronomique et que ce
télescope astronomique a été utilisé
pour faire la réception de la lumière
alors ont utilisé un émetteur sur un des
deux une des devises il fit le télescope
astronomique sur l'autre puis bien sûr
avec ce beau temps ça aide pour avoir
une belle communication en ligne droite
alors je reviens maintenant la
téléportation des personnes est ce qu'il
y ait entre ce que je vous ai raconté
que la téléportation des personnes ben
on peut parfaitement imaginer que si je
voulais téléporter une personne je
devrais comme élaborer un plan qui me
dit exactement quelles sont les
constituants de la personne et que je
raffine mon plan au niveau des molécules
le nouveau déat tombe au niveau
subatomiques que là j'ai besoin
d'obtenir l'information quantique
mais si je voulais faire un téléporteur
pour un être humain et puis je dise pas
que je suis comment faire un si je
voulais faire un thé l'important pour un
être humain il faudrait que les
téléporteurs utilisent les tricks à sion
quantique
il faudrait que les téléporteurs et une
connexion étriqué entre le point de
départ et le point d'arrivée qui
permettrait de non seulement téléporter
la personne que l'on veut transmettre
mais aussi toute l'information qui cache
à l'intérieur dans le monde quantique
puis alors une fois que l'information
est arrivée on peut
créer exactement c'est pas une copie
c'est une réplication exactes de
l'original qui nous permet donc de faire
les téléportations d'un être humain
mais la question à laquelle il faut
répondre c'est sommes-nous quantique
c'est à dire est-ce que c'est pertinent
ce que je viens de vous raconter est ce
que c'est important de savoir si les
êtres humains sont des sons des objets
courants tic puisque c'est important de
sa la téléportation de la partie comme
antique de l'être humain
ou est ce qu'on peut se contenter de
faire une vulgaire copie comme un fax
puis que si on téléporter sont
téléportés mois dans une foire du lte
bout qu'on est juste il est parti mais
monuc hull puis le reste
approximativement ça change rien
la réalité c'est que je n'ai pas la
réponse à cette question là j'en sais
rien ok je suis pas là pour vous
convaincre que demain matin on va faire
des téléporteurs pour les êtres humains
je suis là pour vous dire que si on fait
de la téléportation
il va falloir le faire de cette façon là
mais je veux quand même vous dire que la
téléportation quelques gelées décrites
ne permettrait pas de faire de la copie
pourquoi parce que 2 500 m 1 sec
quand je lis l'information quantique je
détruis l'original pour refaire une une
réplication conforme mais pas une copie
alors je conclure sur l'idée suivante
depuis une vingtaine d'années les
chercheurs sont en train de développer
ce qu'on appelle un ordinateur quantique
saisi un ordinateur ou la mémoire à
l'intérieur de la machine serait
complètement des états quantiques et ça
ça va nous permettre de faire des
calculs de façon plus d'une façon
révolutionnaire sont beaucoup plus
rapides efficaces que ce qu'on a
maintenant et dans un avenir pas trop
éloigné jeux steam 2037
on va obtenir ce qu'on appelle des
ordinateurs quantiques
puis les ordinaires
aquatique pour parler entre eux ils vont
avoir besoin de les téléportations
quantique que je vous ai décrites et
donc la téléportation quantique c'est
pas juste une fantaisie pour téléporter
des gens ou des choses comme ça mais
c'est quelque chose qui veut devenir
technologiquement très concret est
courant dans un monde futur où on aura
des ordinateurs quantiques et ça c'est
pas si loin
alors je vous laisse là dessus je vous
remercie beaucoup